it's an event where athletes competition
is being overshadowed by safety
precautions security has been beefed up
massively throughout the Big Apple for
this year's marathon the police
department has been consulting with
colleagues in Boston in the wake of the
bombings of that cities marathon last
April which killed three and wounded 260
some of the amateur runners who won a
slot in the lottery are apprehensive
including jennifer beer when I told my
nine-year-old that I had been selected
her first response was mom is there
going to be a bomb New York Police
Commissioner Ray Kelly is confident he's
touting the 2,000 extra surveillance
cameras in addition the city has
deployed five additional helicopters
scuba divers and 49 sniffer dogs
specially trained to find explosives I
think it will be safe as it's ever been
so long route 26 miles but we will have
significant resources 26 miles which end
in Manhattan Central Park some 48,000
runners are expected to take part in the
43rd edition of the race a citywide
celebration that draws runners and
viewers from all over the world